The first anxiety disorder that we're going to to discuss, is generalized
anxiety disorder. This is a common disorder that's characterized by a pervasive
and excessive, hard to control, state of anxiety, or worry, that lasts at least
6 months. People with generalized anxiety disorder, may also have trouble with
sleep. Body restlessness or agitation. Difficulty concentrating or muscle
tension. Adults must exhibit at least three of these symptoms. To receive a
diagnosis of generalized anxiety disorder. Unlike other anxiety disorders,
people with generalized anxiety disorder often have been anxious their whole
lives, and they can't recall the particular time when they began to feel this
way. These people tend to worry about anything and everything, and their level
of worry is not proportional to the actual threat they're worried about. A pop
culture example of an individual with generalized anxiety disorder is, Woody
Allen, the writer, director and comedian. He has said that using film making
and being creative has been a distraction from his pervasive anxiety. Now
finally, it's important to remember that feeling anxious towards specific
events is totally normal. But, for people with generalized anxiety disorder,
their anxiety can be debilitating. And for some, it may even prevent them from
being able to work.